democrats are furious at the
authoritarian
fascist terrible no good mean guy donald
trump
because when they asked him whether or
not he will peacefully transfer power
to joe biden he didn't give them exactly
the answer that they wanted will you
commit to making sure that there is a
peaceful transferal of power
after the election well we're gonna have
to see what happens you know that i've
been complaining very strongly about
the ballots and the ballots are a
disaster and
that but people are rioting do you
commit to making sure that there's a
peaceful transfer
we want to have get rid of the ballots
and you'll have a very trans we'll have
a very peaceful
there won't be a transfer frankly
there'll be a continuation
the ballots are out of control you know
it and you know who knows it better than
anybody else the democrats know it
better than anybody else go ahead
mr president will you give power over to
joe biden yeah i don't think we're going
to have to do that
but but but the riots do you hear that
the riots he actually admits the
question was obviously ridiculous in the
first place
it's just a setup of are you going to to
turn over power to the democrats he says
well you know you guys are engaging in
election fraud right now but i don't
think we're gonna need to worry about
that
and then the guy admits it the reporter
he says
but there are riots in the streets we're
rioting in the streets we're already
committing violence
why won't you be intimidated into
peacefully giving us power
we're violently trying to take the power
away from you so why won't you
peacefully
give it to us i don't think so people
who are burning down the country
and burning down our political regime
don't get to lecture us
about peace by the way in other american
cities up in flames i'm michael knowles
that's the michael show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday comes from
zyphon7
on youtube who says breaking key
democrat
says he will not hold up the supreme
court nominee referring of course to
mitt romney
that is not fair mitt romney is playing
nice with us right now
i that is such a mean mean mostly
completely accurate true thing to say
but look mitt's doing pretty well now
he's come along over it looked like he
was going to hold up a good
conservative judge but now he will not i
got to tell you it was a pretty close
shave folks but not as close to shave as
harry's shave
was that how is that segue i love
harry's glad to welcome them to the show
i shaved with harry's just this morning
and i've tried a lot of razor companies
in my life okay i've actually had one
razor i've changed the blades thankfully
since i was about 16 17 years old
harry's is unbelievable it is so
sleek looking it is so simple you say no
way could this give you the best shave
it does the blades are incredible it is
smooth in a very close shave so i
wondered
how on earth could they do that because
harry is very inexpensive they are not
raising the cost
of their blades even as they innovate
the technology and make them sharper the
blades are still as low
as two dollars each you can find new
harry's
sharper blades in big box drug stores
grocery stores places you get them
if you like to shop online you can also
get them if you are
new us customers you can get a trial
offer of harry's new blades
by going to harrys.com knowles they are
extremely sharp
how because harry owns a factory in
germany that has been making and honing
blades
for over 100 years well that makes a lot
of sense they also source all of their
steel
from sweden uh you can totally rely on
these guys there's 100 quality guarantee
the thing about razer blades is they
should all be the same right except
they're not what it comes down to is the
quality of the steel
the quality of the production harry's
has the best you can get them in the big
box drugstore
or if you like to shop online new us
customers get
a harry's trial set right now at harry's
dot com
slash knowles k w l e s get a five blade
razor
featuring their new sharper blades a
weighted handle foaming shaves y'all
with aloe
and this is my favorite part a little
travel cover to protect
your blades and to protect your bags
i've ripped up a number of
of travel bags because i put my razor in
there and it tears them up not with
harry's because
you've got a little protective travel
kit they think of everything harrys.com
knowles redeem your trial offer today i
cannot recommend this product
highly enough democrats are lecturing us
on the peaceful transition of power do
you see anything wrong with that
is anything a little bit weird about
that
they did this by the way in 2016.
hillary clinton said they asked him the
same question and it's a total set up
question
and thankfully donald trump doesn't take
the bait the question is
mr president when you inevitably lose uh
or when we inevitably steal the election
from you are you willing to roll over
and let us take all of the power from
you
and through you the people who voted for
you in this country
and he says uh yeah i don't i'm not
gonna really answer that question i
don't think i think you guys are a bunch
of
propagandists and hacks for the
democrats i'm not i'm not gonna answer
that you got a lot of problems
and what happened in 2016 hillary
clinton said donald trump
is threatening not to accept the results
of the election
he is a threat to democracy and then
what happened donald trump won
and hillary clinton still has not
accepted the results of the 2016
election she didn't accept them on
election night she frankly hasn't
accepted them to this day well they're
doing the same old thing again
except this year it's even more
ridiculous because i don't know if you
guys are history buffs or nothing but
what have democrats been doing for the
past six months
oh right burning down the country
burning down multiple u.s cities
with the encouragement it's not just the
rioters in the streets
it's not just the people organizing and
funding the rioters in the streets
blm and antifa it's the elected
officials
it's the people in the mainstream media
it's the leftists in academia who fuel
give the intellectual fuel to the
leftist
administrative state it's everybody in
that liberal establishment
has been pushing this violence they
don't get to lecture the mean old orange
man
they they don't you know that it's funny
because they make donald trump had to be
this
this authoritarian strong man what is he
known for
he's known for pulling troops out of the
middle east he's known for
establishing historic peace treaties not
only in the middle east
also in serbia kosovo he's known for
actually doing what he says he was going
to do as president and
the liberals cannot take it they do not
get to
lecture us so of course they're burning
down another city i think i can stop
writing my show i don't think i need to
plan my show at before we go live
i don't even think i need to read the
news anymore i think as long as i have a
producer
just sub in the new city whatever the
new city is every day
i can keep the exact same structure in
my show which is
democrats are burning another city and
today's city is spin the wheel
louisville louisville yes they're
burning down that city
this time not because a cop used force
justly or unjustly most of the time the
vast majority of the time turns out
cops are justly using force but that
doesn't matter they always
riot over it anyway this is not because
a cop
used force this is not because a cop got
off the hook
for using force justly or unjustly
right now the radical left is burning
down louisville
and shooting people and killing people
trying to kill people
because a cop was only charged with a
class
d felony for using force
rather than a more serious felony the
cop didn't even get off the hook
for using force which may well have been
justified
but they what do they want to do i guess
they want him to be hanged drawn and
quartered
this comes back to the brianna taylor
case which has been
probably in a way even more than george
floyd the central issue of the past
six months of blm riots it's the one
where they say say her name
rihanna taylor now of course everyone's
saying her name so i don't know what
they have to say say that her name
but the case of brianna taylor is
brianna taylor was
dating and very very possibly working
with
this drug trafficker and there are
people who've gone on the record to say
she was working with the drug trafficker
and this drug trafficker may have been
using her identity and her
address to deal in these drugs she is
with the drug trafficker
in the apartment the cops get a no knock
warrant to search the place
so this is why no knock warrants where
you don't have to knock and say who you
are before you go in
that's why they've been a hot button
political issue but it's it's pretty
stupid that they've become a hot button
political issue because the issue here
was
the cops didn't use a no knock warrant
the cops knocked which allowed
this drug trafficker to grab a gun and
start shooting at the cops
so then the cops shoot back and sadly
uh this this guy's girlfriend brianna
taylor goes down in the scuffle
we don't know totally her involvement in
the drug trafficking operation we just
know that she's
we know at the very least she's involved
with this guy we don't know exactly to
what extent so
what happens yesterday or two yes it was
yesterday that this grand jury report
came out
so hard the days all blend together
because the riots happened
so quickly now actually the riots were
about to preempt the grand jury
decision there was already a state of
emergency declared in louisville
because they they knew that anything
that happens in this case is going to
cause people to go out in the street
so this police officer gets charged
on three counts of wanton endangerment
in the first degree
in the death of brianna taylor uh this
this
sergeant is brett hankins henkeson uh
and so while he was charged with wanton
endangerment in the first degree
he was not charged with the more serious
felony
uh related to homicide and so this is a
class d
felony he could serve five years in
prison bayless said at 15 000
dollars sounds about right it might be
even a little bit harsh i don't know i
haven't
seen the details of the case but i
haven't seen any evidence
that this cop was some murderer going
around because he's a racist and he
really hates black ladies
the riots begin riders in louisville
shoot two cops
as of now as of now i'm sure i'm sure
more violence will be to come
this is not spontaneous this is not a
grassroots uprising
this is not a creed occur of a of an
oppressed people
who are finally rising up now this is a
highly
planned event in keeping with a highly
planned
insurrection and a very well-funded
insurrection going on around the country
planned out and executed by people who
want to destroy
the united states and america a united
states of america who are very open
about it by the way
that is the truth okay another word for
truth is veritas and from veritas
publishing we've got to tell you about
our wonderful friends over at thinker
thinker.org t-h-i-n-k-r because there's
no time
for that e we don't have time for this i
love thinker thinker actually is a
sponsor also of my prageru show
the book club so i i have been familiar
with thinker for a long time
and a big fan of them because in our
fast-paced world today
people don't have time to read i know it
because my job is to read and i still
don't really have time to read
at thinker.org what they do is they
summarize the key ideas
from new and noteworthy non-fiction they
give you access to an entire library of
great books in bite-sized form you can
read
or listen if you're on the go you're
driving wherever
you can you can read or listen to
hundreds of titles in a matter of
minutes
you get old classics like dale
carnegie's how to win friends and
influence people
a great book if you're interested in
politics or sales or business
great book to read or recent bestsellers
like jordan peterson's 12 rules for life
they offer a variety of titles across
many many categories including
ben shapiro's right side of history
including matt walsh's the unholy
trinity
and i hope including my upcoming book
which we'll be talking about
you know in the coming days and weeks if
you want to challenge your perceptions
if you want to expand your horizons most
importantly
if you want to sound smart at cocktail
parties go to thinkor.org t-h-i-n-k-r
dot org start a free trial download the
app today let them know you heard about
them on the michael knowles show tell
them let them know
thinker.org all right
this is all planned out this is being
planned from the very top
we actually saw a video from louisville
of a u-haul truck
being pulled up and antifa slash blm
slash
general leftist insurrectionists uh
passing out pre-made signs
passing out armor passing out tools
that these riders can use to attack cops
and to attack civilians that they don't
like
[Applause]
so here they come all these guys now
they're in uniforms by the way
the antifa guys with some except maybe
one or two exceptions
they're all wearing black all black and
they're taking out these sons abolish
the police abolition now meaning
abolition of our criminal
justice system of our law enforcement
system which what does that mean
i get it look everybody hates the cops
when they get pulled over
right everybody hates the cops when they
get a parking ticket everybody
is really upset at our law enforcement
system sometimes and yet
we're very grateful to the cops into our
law enforcement system because
they allow us to have our property
protected to allow our have our lives
protected
to exist in the system that is so
wonderful
attacks on law enforcement are seductive
because
sometimes everyone gets irritated at the
cops but what they are really
is a symbol for an attack on
our law on our nation itself
the cops the law enforcement or the
symbol of
the nation of laws that we have and so
they attack the cops somebody's paying
for these u-holes somebody's
somebody's paying to for these people to
communicate
somebody is organizing them
this group is antifa they are
working in tandem over the past six
months
with blm and a validly marxist
organization
we are told that antifa does not exist
that's what the mainstream leftist told
us they don't exist right
well if they don't exist if it's just a
little local phenomena pops up in
portland but how come it pops up in
louisville if it pops up in louisville
and this is a a louisville issue right
this issue of the brianna taylor case
why were there riots yesterday in
washington dc
as well and if there's not an
organization called antifa
how come they wave a flag cnn cnn
actually had to admit this
and they had been pushing this whole
thing antifa is not real forget about
antifa
well finally during the the mayhem in dc
last night cnn admits
that these people are organized and
they're organized under the same banner
there are restaurants and bars and
apartments chanting all sorts of things
anti-gentrification slogans
anti-police slogans some have been
banging on uh on street signs with
batons and bats
fireworks have been have been fired off
we've seen graffiti sprayed
uh on a variety of buildings and even
seen an antifa flag
clearly being flown and waved at the
front of the march
but i thought they didn't exist how do
they have a flag if they're not a real
organization how come they have uniforms
and equipment
and a flag and funding and they're in
multiple cities they're all over the
country because of course they do exist
so cnn had to change its tune on this
and cnn actually
showed the flag later on in the cli you
can actually see it
in the the coverage antifa walks right
by the camera
waving their flag i want to go to cnn's
alex marquardt
uh in washington where protesters have
done lemon cutting right back to him
yeah uh don you know protesters took to
the streets uh
in huge numbers in the wake of george
floyd's death and they are back out in
the streets of washington tonight
uh this is the crowd here at 11 p.m
eastern time uh this group gathered
around four hours ago he's been on the
march now for the past two leaving from
the white house and really doing a big
loop around washington dc
anti-fed just these protesters at least
they weren't burning down any buildings
in that particular shot so he could
almost credibly call them protesters and
you see don lemon cutting to it
don lemon who previously
defended antifa this is a little bit of
a change in tune
for cnn not totally because they're not
totally condemning them here
but don lemon went on tv went on cnn
and defended this antifa organization
which targets
civilians to achieve political ends do
you know do you know what that's called
that's terrorism that's the base
definition of terrorism
antifa which tears down
property which burns down buildings
which
attacks cops which tries to kill
civilians which sometimes succeeds at
killing civilians
don lemon said hey not every
organization is perfect
it says it right in the name antifa anti
fascism which is what they were there
um fighting listen there's you know no
organization is perfect there's some
violence
um no one condones the violence but
there are different reasons for antifa
and for these neo-nazis
to be there one racist
fascists the other group fighting racist
fascists there is a fascist there's a
distinction there
hey look antifa they're really good
they're anti-fascist
okay yes sometimes they kill civilians
that's i guess that's
that's not good you know but no one's
perfect and uh look nobody condones
violence but also antifa is really good
that was the that was the compliment
sandwich
that don lemon prepared for antifa right
big compliment
minor criticism big compliment but let's
zoom in on that minor criticism
no organization's perfect i guess that's
true yeah okay they're a little violent
yep they're more than a little violent
no one condones violence well that's not
true
the left is condoning violence not
radicals even not extremists
but leftists on
don lemon's own network i mean he in his
compliments
is tacitly condoning the violence but
even his
ostensibly more moderate counterpart
chris cuomo
is explicitly condoning the violence
just a few weeks ago chris cuomo goes on
tv
to defend the riots and he says wait a
second since when do protests have to be
peaceful
and please show me where it says that
protests are supposed to be polite
and peaceful the first amendment that's
where it says that you have a right to
peaceably assemble
not a right to burn down cities but just
more evidence that
well well the left is going to tell you
as the cities burn and their poll
numbers go down so they have to start
slightly going after antifa and they say
look no one condones violence
they have been condoning violence this
entire time and they've been encouraging
it the entire time
and now they're going to try to lie to
you and tell you that they haven't and
they're going to tell you that orange
man bad because he doesn't want a
peaceful transfer of power
the left is engaging in political
violence
to steal political power away from the
duly elected president
and they've been doing it for six months
at least
i don't ever want to hear that word come
out of their mouth
again peace peaceful they've lost their
privileges to use that word they've lost
their privileges
to lecture me on the peaceful transfer
of power
when you use violence and you try to
steal an election i'm done there's no
why are we even having this conversation
with them anymore
it next time some reporter asks trump
that question he shouldn't even give it
he should just move on
move on to the next reporter who's going
to ask another stupid question
and i actually don't even mean just to
attack the mainstream media here they
are just
tools pushing this violence
the intellectual heft pushing this
violence goes much deeper goes into the
heart of academia so you might be asking
okay there's this
totally fine grand jury decision that
comes out in the brianna taylor case
which has been completely
misrepresented by the mainstream media
and that's fine that's in louisville
why are there riots in dc well okay i'll
i'll do you one more
why is the president of ohio state
university
weighing in on the alleged injustice of
a case
that she knows nothing about that's
exactly what happened when ohio state
president christina
johnson said more or less
in a kind of boring academic but
nonetheless radical way
no justice no peace brianna taylor
deserves justice
and this does not feel like justice we
cannot accept what has happened in
louisville
we grieve the tragic and senseless loss
of brianna taylor
a daughter a friend a niece
a loved one who was unarmed and asleep
the breakdown in the justice system and
the killings of
unarmed black and brown people in our
country has become all too familiar
tragically
this isn't going to stop until we create
an anti-racist world
we must come together to draw strength
from each other and advance our
collective vision
for a better world where we one day have
justice for all
there is much work to be done that's so
creepy
she's talking like a brainwashed person
it's funny because she's leading one of
the institutions that does the
brainwashing but she's just some
administrative hack
right i mean she's just the president of
the university used to be that
presidents of the university were
serious
academics this woman i don't think so
but she just repeats
the talking points and notice that she
goes this will never go away we can
never have justice
until we have an anti-racist world
anti-racist now in that phrase nobody
would object to that right
but anti-racist obviously doesn't mean
anti-racist it means the opposite of
that it means a
very racist world and beyond that a very
violent world a very unjust world
but they use the term anti-racist in the
same way that antifa uses the term
anti-fascist
you got antifa you got antera anti-rise
the anti-racists
but it doesn't mean anti-racist at all
both of those things antifa and antera
very very bad because what they mean is
a total racial bigotry
bigotry of other sorts as well and
ultimately what it boils down to is
injustice ruled by a mob that has a
wicked evil vision
of the good ruled by a mob that is a
validly anarchistic
that is sometimes avowedly marxist
in the case of blm ruled by very
very very bad people who want to tear
down everything good that we cherish in
the world
you know marx who is sort of the big
mack daddy godfather of all of these
movements
marx famously called for we said it
yesterday on the show the
ruthless criticism of all that exists
his conception of the good that he's
trying to force on society
is just the opposite of what we've all
thought the good is his conception of
human nature totally the opposite of
what we thought
human nature was his conception of
justice totally the opposite of actual
justice
that's what these guys are pushing
that's why it matters when you know you
say oh who cares some
even when you say there's some riot in
some cities okay why do i why do i care
doesn't affect me it doesn't it does
because the intellectual poison of this
movement
is spreading throughout the entire
country and it threatens to tear the
whole thing down
when you are about to lose something
that you cherish
the key to it is not to wait until after
the fact
the key to fixing that is prevention
this is true when you're talking about
losing a country it's also true when
you're losing your hair
how was that segue i was looking forward
to that one so much keeps that's what
i'm talking about keeps
two-thirds of men can lose
their hair very very early you're
talking between
25 and 35 years old you don't think of
it that way you think you're only going
to lose your hair when you're older
you've got to start early if you want to
keep your hair
you used to have to go to a doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps
you can visit a doctor online and get
hair loss medication
delivered right to your home they make
it very easy they deliver it
every three months keeps uses the only
two fda approved hair loss products
maybe you've tried them before you've
never tried them at this
price now keeps treatments i i will warn
you
right up front they they can take four
to six months
to really start working so you've got to
start fast but this is the way to do it
this is the way to keep your hair you
know i'm not like a hulking olympian
adonis of a man okay
one thing i've always had going for me
in the lady department though got a nice
full head of poofy hair over here
you should keep your hair as well it's
very important guys
the treatments start at just 10 bucks a
month okay it is worth
10 bucks a month to you to keep your
hair i promise you you're going to
regret it down the line if you don't do
it
if you're ready to take shot action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
knowledge can wlas receive your first
month of treatment for free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash knowles keep
your hair and we should try to keep
our country in the meantime though
while while the the left is
actively organizing to tear down the
country the so-called moderate leftist
politicians
are dithering away at one of them
sometimes we call him governor hair gel
or
nussolini i consider him to be patrick
bateman from american psycho the only
thing whenever i see
gavin newsom on screen all i can think
of is hey
you ever listen to huey lewis in the
news you know hey paul and then chops
with you with an axe
that is governor newsome he is dithering
he is now talking about we're not
protecting the country from burning down
because of leftist
marauders not protecting the state of
california from burning down
because of his forest mismanagement
which he's even admitted to in the past
he's going to ban cars that's what he's
going to do he's not that's how he's
going to fix the country he's going to
ban
cars in 15 years
thank you governor newsome a goal
firm goal that by 2035 in the next
15 years we will eliminate in the state
of california the sales
of internal combustion engines we will
move forward to
green and decarbonize our vehicle fleet
here in the state of california as a
consequence substantially reducing
greenhouse gas emissions as well as
oxide
nitrogen meaning knox emissions here in
the state of california
in so doing will improve air quality as
well
as improve the economic climate here in
the state of california
this is both stupid and meaningless
it's it's somehow managed to be both
it's stupid in that he says that by
banning automobiles
by banning the vast vast majority of
automobiles he's going to improve the
economy of california
i don't think so and i think the other
measures he's taken to improve the
economy of california
have up plunged it into the depths of
despair
he's saying it's going to improve air
quality do you know what's causing there
to be
bad air quality right now in california
do you know why i'm getting alerts on my
phone because of bad air quality
the fires that are burning down because
of his forest mismanagement
and in fairness to new some decades of
democratic forest mismanagement in
california
that's why the air quality is bad it's
not because somebody's driving a honda
it's not because we don't all have
teslas so it's very stupid
but where newsome really manages to
achieve something
is it's also meaningless he says we've
got to do it by 2035.
he's not going to be in office in 2035.
whoever's in office in 2035 very likely
will have to rescind
this stupid order because you can't ban
cars
if you want to keep your economy moving
at all and
the electric cars are the technology is
not perfected
and usually they're worse for the
environment than the regular normal
normal cars that burn gas because
the parts in the electric cars are much
more uh
deleterious to the environment than just
burning burning the gas on your regular
old ford or honda or chevy
what this is about is setting up newsom
to run for president in 2024 or possibly
even 2028
but still both those dates long before
2035 it's a ridiculous
plan how about the leader of the
democratic party how about him does he
have any better ideas no he's trying to
fend off corruption charges
when it is that he can remember where he
is which is not too frequently
joe biden was asked some months ago
about hunter biden's corruption we got
some big news on hunter button
corruption yesterday
joe biden was asked some months ago
about his son hunter because don't
forget it's not just about having a bad
son
who makes some bad deals the son was
trading on the father's
influence when the father was point man
on the issues
that hunter biden was cashing in on when
when the father was the vice president
so it's not just hunter biden's
corruption it's joe biden's corruption
as well
what's joe's answer he doesn't have one
i don't know
what he was doing i know he was on the
board i found out he was on the board
after he was on the board
and that was it and there's nobody well
that's a lot of time isn't this
something you want to get to the bottom
of
no because i trust my son but that
doesn't pass the smell test like when
you're vice president
isn't there a higher standard don't you
need to know what's happening with your
family don't you need to put down
some guard rails unless there was
something that was
there was something on his face that was
wrong there's nothing on his face that
was wrong
so look if you want to talk about
problems you know let's talk about
trump's family
if you want to talk about problems
please don't ask me about my son who was
obviously trading my influence for lots
of money he said there's nothing wrong
on its face
okay so i don't want to i trust my son
well there
turns out there is something wrong on
its face there's a lot wrong on his face
and he shouldn't have trusted his
son we found out why joe biden kept
deflecting his ridiculous answer that he
had no idea what hunter biden was up to
first of all hunter biden admitted
that his father knew what he was up to
so so eventually then joe biden had to
change his tune say yeah i knew but it
wasn't a big deal
so according to this senate report on
hunter biden
hunter biden allegedly sent thousands of
dollars
to people who were involved in sex
trafficking
this according to wednesday's report by
senate republicans
the report claims unspecified records
show that biden
sent funds to non-resident alien women
in the u.s who are citizens of russia
and ukraine
who subsequently then wired funds that
they received
from hunter biden to individuals located
in russia
and ukraine now people are making a big
deal out of this
because sex trafficking is in the news
because of you know jeffrey epstein and
all this
this other crazy stuff that involves a
lot of democrats
that's not the most damning thing i mean
it's it's damning in the sense that it's
very bad but it's something we already
knew about hunter biden which is the guy
went to strip clubs and hookers and he
did that sort of thing so that
you know you hear it as he was
participating in the sex trafficking
ring really what happened is he just
sent thousands of dollars to russian
hookers
that's nothing we didn't know okay that
was that was not not bombshell stuff
but there is some bombshell stuff
involving russia you follow the russia
trail get
get past the hookers get into the much
more serious corruption
hunter biden received a three and a half
million dollar wire transfer from elena
baturina
the richest woman in russia the widow of
yuri luzkov
former mayor of moscow this according to
the senate republicans report
bacharina is mentioned in this 87 page
report
and it addresses this payment to biden
which occurred in 2014
while his father joe biden was vice
president
what we're seeing again and again is
more evidence of a typical democrat
strategy which is
accuse your opponent of your own
corruption
accuse your opponent of your own vices
accuse your opponent
of your own crimes how long did we hear
about the russia hoax
trump colluding with russia we now have
proof
we now have proof positive that
democrats
were the ones colluding with russia
which we should have known about because
they've been pro-russia for 100 years
they've been they've been defending
russia for 100 years during
during stalin's reign they were
defending russia at the beginning of the
obama administration they wanted a reset
with russia
barack obama promised medvedev he said
tell putin that i'm going to be more
flexible after my election i've got to
lie to the american people in the
meantime
but i'm going to be really soft on him
after my election in 2012.
of course they're they're always soft on
russia and now we see that hunter biden
receives millions and millions of
dollars from the richest woman in russia
while his father is vice president why
do you get that money why do you get
that money i don't know
but i know for a fact that the democrats
had to deflect by accusing trump
of of crimes that he never committed
turns out
they did commit them it's the same thing
with the peaceful transfer of power
mr president why won't you commit to the
peaceful transfer of power
because you won't because not not even
that you won't commit
to the peaceful transfer of power you're
promising me you won't transfer power
hillary clinton said explicitly joe
biden should not concede under any
circumstances
doesn't matter if there's a trump
landslide don't concede the democrats
are
funding rioters in the streets
and where they're not funding their
actual equipment
they're funding their positive press
coverage they're funding their
propaganda arm
which might might be called cnn
that's what's going on peaceful transfer
of power i don't think so we
we are now at the stage where anything
the democrats accuse this president of
i have got to assume they are committing
themselves we got to get to the mailbag
so head on over to dailywire.com right
now you know by the way you got to go if
you're watching this on youtube
subscribe to the michael noel show
youtube channel ring the bell over there
september 28th we're going to switch
over only broadcast this show
exclusively
on the michael knowles show youtube
channel not because i'm leaving the
daily wire i assure you
just because we got to get around big
tech head on over there
by the way don't forget september 29th
after
the big debate if the big debate happens
we're gonna have a backstage
i guess we'll have a backstage in any
case so get ready for that head on over
to dailywire.com we'll be right back
with a lot more
first question from grant hey michael
i'm in a slight dilemma
i'm currently seeing an amazing catholic
girl who i want to be serious with
however i have trouble overcoming my
ex's hateful actions against me
lying cheating leading me on the manner
in which she handled our breakup
what she did after our breakup etc and
it's hindering my new relationship
because i'm still so angry at my ex
my ex and i dated for five years until
last november should i man up and do the
christian thing and wish her well
forgive her
what's the best way to do this yet you
clearly know the answer
you set me up for it and then you asked
how to achieve it yes you should man up
and you should do the christian thing
and wish her well and forgive her
maybe more for you than for her you know
you got to forgive her because it sounds
like you're really hung up on this girl
i mean
yeah sure she there are plenty of awful
awful girlfriends in the world and maybe
she lied to you
maybe she cheated on you maybe she led
you on again
maybe she didn't take your breakup well
maybe she did
crazy stuff after your breakup maybe she
boiled your rabbit i don't know
you got a man up just gotta say okay
well
dodged a bullet there sure glad i didn't
marry her you're a lucky man you should
be you should thank this woman
for for showing you who she was before
you got married and stuck with her
forever
sounds from this like you're catholic
when you're catholic
that's it you can't leave the marriage
there's no divorce pal
you can't that is not an option for you
so the fact that you were able to avoid
marrying this apparently awful woman is
a great thing you should thank her for
that so thank you so much
lady for showing me what a terrible lady
that you are
not much of a lady at all perhaps and
now you can be very thankful that you
got this great catholic girl
just yeah get over the x man come on
everybody has ex-girlfriends everybody's
got a past
just move on pat how do how do you get
over this well
i will give you some pagan advice on
this
you seem to know the catholic advice
you've already said it to me you wish
your will you forgive her you work
through this you obviously
order all of your loves toward god uh
great a great little bit of reading on
how to order your love including your
erotic love
uh toward the beloved but then
ultimately through the beloved and up
toward the highest good who is god
is dante dante does that very well it's
a
wonderful poem i recommend it all the
time but then if you want some
a little bit of pagan advice a little
classical antiquity
for for some advice ovid
the the uh latin writer has a book
called
remedia amores the cure for love i'm not
recommending that you do
every single thing he says some of it
you know is a maybe not exactly kosher
but it's a very funny book it's an
enjoyable book to read and it does give
very good practical advice for how to
get over
a a bad breakup
some very basic stuff that he says
that's that's probably
morally illicit uh tear up all of her
photos don't keep her photos don't look
at her facebook page don't look at her
instagram
don't think about her all the time burn
all get rid of that who cares
that lady's done get rid of your
infatuation with her you know
sometimes when you realize that
someone's a terrible person but you
still feel
feelings of love for them it's not love
it's infatuation you're not thinking
about the actual person
you're just thinking about your own
sentimental gloss that you've put over
this person
and that's that is sinful that's that's
not a good thing so get rid of that he
also has some advice that you know
probably you shouldn't do but you know
your mileage may vary give it a read
that's
that's
my advice for you from daniel dear
stogie smoking don of the intellectual
dark web
since the democrats threatening to pack
the supreme court if given
the power in november should the
republicans if we win
the presidency senate and house
representatives try to amend the
constitution
to solidify the court size to nine no i
don't see any reason to do that
the constitution doesn't set the court
size i don't
know that we need necessarily a fixed
court size at nine
if we win the presidency the senate in
the white house we're going to be able
to appoint
another judge breyer probably is the
next step he's the next eldest judge
he's a big lib
so you could get another conservative
there then you've got a 7-2
court now that you could you could waste
your time trying to amend the
constitution it's very difficult to
amend the constitution that's why it
hasn't been done very many times in
american history
in this divided country i don't know
that you want to waste your political
capital on that i don't think you would
necessarily succeed
actually scalia before he died he was
asked what
he actually may have died i got to meet
the guy twice and i think it was
actually one time when i was there
visiting him with a group of other
students at the supreme court we said
what would you change about the
constitution he said i'd make it easier
to amend
he actually thinks it's a weakness of
the constitution that it's so hard to
amend
but his observation nevertheless is true
it's very difficult to amend so i
wouldn't waste the political capital on
that
i would just enjoy a very conservative
court
if we win in november i would put your
political capital and focus it on actual
substantive policy goals
both in the administrative government
through executive order and then through
legislation if you can win back the
senate in the house
if they want to legislate which they
usually don't and then i would
make sure that we get a lot of great
cases going up to the court and a lot of
great decisions out of it from christy
hey michael we have another question
from the daily wire autonomous zone
dwaz as we call it now that you're
moving to nashville when do we get
pictures of the whole crew in cowboy
hats and boots
also did daily wire pick nashville so
that you and jeremy can make your duet
take your duet on the road and play in
some dive bars i'm sure we can help your
band find a really good name thanks i
would love it if you could help name
my uh duet my folk rock band with jeremy
boring if you could give us a name maybe
put in the comments email it in through
dailywire or whatever i would really
appreciate that because we're looking
for a name
i do have cowboy boots that i got from
takovas on this show
and you know they're very very
comfortable i don't know that i can pull
the look off terribly well
but if but but they do they are very
very comfortable and i think in
nashville i'm gonna have to
the cowboy hat is the harder one because
my head is shaped like a peanut
so it's just not it's not built for hats
that's that's kind of the problem but
i'll tell you what if you maybe
photoshop it on give me a few
few options maybe i'll be able to get
there from
michael great name love the show good
luck in nashville my question is how do
you think never trump republicans at
this point
can still consider themselves to be
pro-life the candidate they're backing
is clearly not pro-life thanks
yeah i mean i i don't know how
they organize their thought because it's
not logical and it's not coherent but
the key what is it that it never was
never trump was always based on a moral
error a moral miscalculation i get that
it was much harder in 2016.
we had all these knock-down drag-out
fights obviously not just in the daily
water but in the conservative movement
broadly about
about never trump and i i see the
argument for never trump
especially in 2016 which is i don't know
maybe he'll be a democrat maybe he'll be
more liberal than we think he's too
crass he's this he's that whatever
but the moral miscalculation is that
the never trump movement was based on
the idea that the election is not
a binary choice but it is the election
in america the presidential election is
a binary choice
there are only two candidates who
possibly can win
there is no such thing as a third party
candidate there is no such thing as egg
mcmuffin
or whatever that guy's name was evan
mcmullen in 20 it was he ran to be a
spoiler for the republicans
or gary johnson or joe
jorgensen or whatever the libertarian
party or the green party or this and
that's not real when you when you vote
for one of those guys you were voting
to take away a vote from your political
party
your two major political parties that's
actually a good thing because it gives
people a choice
the parties aren't perfect they're far
from it but they give people an actual
choice
and the parties as they become
quote-unquote polarized
have made clearer choices you know
phyllis schlafly
said early on in the postwar
conservative movement she said we need a
choice
not an echo the two parties were too
similar at that time
you didn't know if you vote for a
democrat he might be more conservative
than a republican in some cases
so now the parties are pretty clear you
do have a choice and
the the never trump movement tried to
pretend that there's no such thing as
the binary choice that you win politics
by losing the idea was we'll lose this
election and then we're going to win
stronger in four years that doesn't
happen that's not how politics works
you don't win by losing you win by
winning and you can only win when you
take moral risk
and maybe things don't turn out well and
maybe you have egg on your face and
maybe you feel bad about it but the only
way you're going to win is by embracing
that
imperfection because politics is not
perfect abstract ideology which is
which is always a divorce from reality
it's not even perfect philosophy
it's imperfect reality flesh and bones
real decisions being made so it's wrong
then it's much clearer that it's wrong
now
and i don't know who were the only
they're like three never trumpers left
in the whole country
it's not real it's not real anymore
because i think people have recognized
that
from sarah congrats on moving to
nashville there's a lot of like
nashville
questions today my question is what do
you think was the worst part of living
in los
angeles and who do you put the blame on
for destroying arguably the best piece
of land in the u.s
yeah it is great land luckily you still
get orange county it's so beautiful
and san diego is very very beautiful and
santa barbara is very beautiful
so la they've made it less and less
beautiful but it is
it is gorgeous land that has been
destroyed and it's destroyed because
it's a company town for hollywood
and hollywood is owned by the left and
it's been owned by the left for at least
50 years now at least since the 70s or
so it wasn't
wasn't always totally left-wing
dominated um
but but it is now once the studio system
broke up that was it i know
you're probably asking for a political
issue when did
this this issue or that issue you know
they raised taxes and that's what
destroyed l.a that's not it you actually
have to look a little past the
politicians
into what constitutes the town it is a
showbiz town it's a hollywood town
and hollywood has always been a morally
compromised
institution uh this goes back even when
it was ostensibly conservative that we
would
call it gamora by the sea you know it's
all it's always had that reputation the
casting couch and all that kind of stuff
nothing nothing about that is new
but what changed was it used to be run
with some business sensibility and with
some patriotism
and with some understanding of how labor
relates to the studios
and that was called the studio system
and that was back when hollywood was was
full of real jobs
and real contracts right then after the
studio system is broken up by the
supreme court
then you've got this free-for-all and
this really expands in the 70s and 80s
and 90s and then
people don't really have jobs so it's a
bunch of vagrants in cafes writing
screenplays that are never going to be
produced
people going on auditions for roles
they're never going to get people trying
to direct movies that no one's ever
going to see
and this creates a lot of
chaos in in hollywood and idle hands are
the devil's playground it increases
the the sort of vice of the city somehow
it was already a
somewhat vicious city and the the
political issues follow from there and
it has it has gotten appreciably worse
over time now of course it's just
needles and
and defecation and all sorts of
craziness in the streets
but not us in the streets anymore
because we're getting out of there and a
lot of people are as well i've got to
get out of here today but i will see you
on monday i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen
you